computers are dumb
they can only answer questions
you know and i think the point is
the hard part is asking the questions
right the our part is something that
that only us creative people can do
and so if we're not enabling people to
do more if we're just trying to automate
or take away
work from them
um or you know just gather data for the
sake of gathering it we haven't done
anything
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
i love talking to fast-growing startups
meet sega liao the co-founder and ceo of
tone king
tonkin is the operating system for
business operations transforming
operations teams from facilitators into
makers with an enterprise grade no code
process orchestration platform
by abstracting the technical knowledge
required to automate monitor and manage
mission critical business processes
while still maintaining compliance and
security tonkin enables enterprises to
accelerate operational velocity at scale
founded in 2015 tonkin is headquartered
in san francisco with r d in tel aviv
[Music]
welcome to 20 minute leaders how are you
good man thanks for having me
thank you very very much for joining me
from san francisco and running a really
really cool company tonkin
which i just learned is type of a monkey
so and you'll explain to me that the
name choice in a second but until then
you know the whole the whole idea of
data-driven companies data-driven
decisions the intersection of business
and business and intelligence and and
how processes are being made within
businesses i think it's fascinating and
i think it's it's fascinating in a
changing world with an accelerated
globalization with remote work and and
decisions having to be made across a
variety of of disciplines within
companies and and so i i you can see
already that i'm really excited about
what you're doing
before we even dive into what i just
said who is sega liao
well again thank you for having me
michael i'm ceo and founder of tonkin
and um
um i like to say that uh i'm a software
guy at heart
you know i've been been writing coaches
i was 10 years old type of thing
but i had you know had experience in the
opportunity to grow
as a leader and
and an executive in in public company
before starting tanking
and so
i'm very
bullish about this space as well
and i actually like to say that you know
we started talking about six years ago
so think you know i'm excited to see
your excitement because let me tell you
six years ago no one understood what i
want from them
i can imagine it's a good time
i can imagine
six take me back six years ago you're
sitting you're thinking you're looking
at the world what what are you observing
so
you know the
there's a benefit always to come into
a room for the first time right you look
around and everything is new for you you
don't have the baggage
of you know what is the status quo how
you know the things we use the way we
used to do things um and
that's kind of what happened to me um i
was
i was in the army in israel um
in the intelligent unit
i you know joined a small startup we got
acquired by uh by a
public
tech company
and i got the opportunity to grow there
relatively quickly and grow a team there
so we actually grew the uh the team in
israel from about seven people we were
in the startup to over 150 people and
and i was leading this group and then i
moved with this company here to the bay
area that's how i ended up here
originally
and um and at that point had over 300
people under me so no longer engineering
more you know more global
in different different parts of the
business
but i was new to all of it you know i
sort of grew into it and i had my
engineering and software experience but
not necessarily operation experiences so
every time i came to you know whether it
was an executive staff meeting or an
off-site or whether it was just like
ordinary decision making
i just felt like things are
weird i was strange
are inefficient or
you know there i say old
in the way we do it and it's it's a
known thing that
you know development and r d usually are
you know a few steps ahead
with um with technology in general but
even with
you know methodology and how how you
operate because you need to sort of keep
up with the technology
um advance advances right but the rest
of the business how do you manage legal
how do you manage sales how do you
manage you know marketing how do you
manage finance
it's all about lagging if you will in in
the methodologies and the tools you're
using
and i just felt like honestly
there's a huge huge mismatch between the
technology we have
and what we need in order to run a
business and so
to kind of you know the highlight that a
lot of people talk about like what is
this so like um
you know that that light bulb moment
for me it was i realized that the
business business processes that we all
do all the time
are not actually about data
they're about people
but hundred percent of software in the
organization is about data you know move
data around you log data you view data
and um
and and the things we've built are not
built for how people work
in
in in fact we're changing the way people
work in order to fit to the tools we
have and that's just felt like a a big
enough problem for me to solve and so um
so i started to um you know join forces
with my my co-founder and start talking
so you're sitting there and you're
thinking okay how in the world am i
gonna
change the way businesses are run from
the inside how processes are on how
decisions are being made
not letting the the data be the the
epicenter of of all the decisions but
but allowing the people to make to run
the processes how do you even begin to
rationalize through what type of product
you can build to make that happen
it's hard
in fact it you know
it took six it took to be honest three
years for us to really start a break
through wow um so only three years ago
is really when you know things start to
rapidly turn for us um the first three
years
are a combination of that sort of
trial and error you know trying to
figure this out and trying to
better understand where the market is
currently and
you know um how do we take that concept
that is very emotional
to me but not as you know what the
beginning wasn't as like practical so
how do you kind of turn it into a
practical solution
uh but to be honest the market wasn't
there too so there's other things that
are important
um
you know
digital transformation is just a huge
thing for the last 10 years
with the cloud and everything and today
a lot more companies
are in the cloud but not everyone still
but it's a different situation that than
it was six years ago it was ten years
ago that's one thing right uh apis you
know just the concept of
companies building products and
understanding that there need to be part
of an ecosystem
you know is an obvious thing now it was
not obvious 10 years ago was less
obvious six years ago so a lot of those
things you know are
uh the the the world is moved to it but
even
automation people that
you know know about the space a little
bit of no code low code and automation
in general that concept of not every
problem
should be solved necessarily with buying
an off-the-shelf product just this
mental thinking
is also something that you know sort of
grew as a market
you know side by side with our uh
personal growth as a company
and so it really sort of met in the
middle i like to say you know about
three years ago
right
also
process
the
when you're when you're approaching
companies and you're and you're talking
about the way processes are on the way
data is is run within an organization
how receptive are they you know you just
you know for even from the light libel
moment you know when three years ago
things started to turn
how how receptive are they the first
time they're thinking critically about
okay
we have running an operation here we
might actually be doing we might
actually be making decisions without the
right tools
yeah i think it comes down to
two things
one
the investment
or the priority for companies to invest
in improving operations
um that's almost like a culture shift
the understanding that
we need to invest in how we do things
just as much as investing in what we do
and
kovid
you know is terrible but
but on from uh from a from a
prioritization stand was actually very
inducive moment because what happened
was
change is all of a sudden not a
theoretical thing that you need to be
afraid of it literally just happened
everyone had to change everything about
how they work whether it's remote
whether it's the shutdowns whether it's
the fact that your customers and
consumers change their behavior
that change
was not again not no longer a
theoretical thing it was an immediate
thing that you have to adapt to and if
you don't you die it's very simple it's
as simple as that
and so all of a sudden companies
that um even big companies which i can
talk in a second like type of companies
we work with
that never had operational efficiency or
operational excellence in their top you
know three
company-wide initiatives are now kind of
made the cut and became like the number
one or number two number three
goals no longer only revenue or only
customer satisfaction but also
operational official excellence and
operation efficiency so that's the first
things like what is the
why would you even listen to me like why
what why is that even matter right and
then the second thing is
what does it actually mean though what
does it mean to change your um to up
level your operation the way you
leverage technology for it so one thing
that people need to understand
is that nothing have ever happens in you
know in a silo it's like it's it's a
movement
um and you maybe even know it yourself
you know 10 years ago you had um roles
like dev operation developer operations
devops and sales operations those are
about 10 years old
to d but it was all
basically the only type of operations
you had today every department as an
operation teams
you know you have legal operations and
finance operations and i.t operations
and compliance operations and hr
literally name uh you know a department
and they now have an operation role
uh that's part of that investment that's
part of that understanding that you need
to put people
to think about how are they gonna
improve
the the operation the processes as a
full-time job not as after a fact that
something doesn't work let's fix it
right but like i said
what is the technology what is the
methodology that is available for them
to actually iterate
um and so
without getting into too much details
you you can think about what we're
trying to bring to customers from our
product and our capabilities similar to
the same to the to the
invention of
the assembly line in a factory floor
you know before
there was a time in history where
factories ran
as a stations of work some having
machines some just people sitting
together and literally the people that
were handling the process where people
were you know wearing a yellow vest
yelling yes the process was something
you print on the wall
um right
and then the industrial revolution
literally
started from that simple concept of we
need to orchestrate the work
not only execute the work better but the
way we actually move the work around the
factory floor needs to be orchestrated
uh even if there's still station of work
that are humans and not only machines
it's not only connecting machines it's
actually orchestrating coordinating the
entire thing and so that's what we're
trying to bring to businesses to enable
those operation teams to build their own
costume solutions
without writing any code so 100 no code
in a composable fashion so and there's a
lot of big words but it's it's it's it's
basic simple concepts of hey take the
the parts that you already have and
think about them as lego blocks
right and build your own solution with
those blocks um that fits your need
uh perfectly so you can actually now
start to optimize it and iterate on it
um
i i'd love to to pick your brain on you
know as you started mentioning that you
love software right that's we started
the conversation and i think that
there's an interesting question here to
be asked which is
you know this idea of generalization
versus customization and you know we're
talking about
you know building software building a
product that is that is aiming to allow
you know generalized group of companies
create customized solutions for them
without using code themselves right
without having to go and tweak the
product in any way it's basically taking
two polar opposites and and building
them in one what is that process like
either from a technological perspective
or from a business perspective
it is actually comes down to that um
to that compose
composable approach and you know the
funny thing about bringing software
into
you know
different places and believing in
software it's not only the technical
part of the software is the mental
concept of it the ability to
build whatever you need like what
software really gives
uh in a digital world that we live in
it's a it's a it's a superpower you can
build whatever you want you know i mean
it's like it's all digital it's all
software so if you can build software
you can build whatever you want but you
know what the percentage of people that
can code in the in the world
guess
i would go with 0.1
not far half half less than half a
percent
um 0.4
and
it's nothing if you think about it
nothing it's really
i like to think about it if if you think
about humanity as a tribal in a tribal
state you have like they have a hundred
people in a tribe
if only half a person could build things
only the kid can code yeah we won't
survive you know what i mean um so the
percentage of people that can actually
build things figure problems figure out
problems find solutions
i call those type of people makers
and the idea is the makers they see a
problem they don't raise their hand like
hey guys there's a problem
instead they're like oh i wonder how i
can fix it and this is not statistic
statistically accurate because i don't
know if i can count it but just
logically speaking again going back to
that tribe example
there's got to be at least 20 30 percent
or by minimum 10 of the population that
our makers because otherwise again we
won't survive right right and then this
and just to make it clear you when
you're what you're calling a maker this
is not a professional tree this is a
personal characteristic of the way we
approach problems and solutions right
exactly and the only difference between
a maker and a coder in this example just
like a difference between a maker and a
woodworker is the skill set
and the right tools that they have in
order to do that to you know to to
bring solutions to life
they already have the personality and
the capability to do it you know even
this podcast was much harder to do in
the past with all the different tools
you had to have like a full studio to do
that so what does this technology allow
you to do to bring people that actually
has that creativity
and bring that to market same goes to
photoshop or other you know design tools
it used to be much more complex
but the abstraction of that complexity
but still allowing you to create
whatever you want to your previous point
right it's a general thing
but it allows to abstract the complexity
what it really does is empower people
that doesn't have the power reduce that
skills gap into people that already have
that you know personal trait so when i
think about
businesses and how businesses run
they're not leveraging technology not
even even though we think oh everything
is softer we're literally using a 0.4
percent of the potential
of what we can do with technology and
the way there is not just shoving more
software and more apps down you know
down the company's throat the opposite
it's enable and empower
more people people that have that role
even you know the operation teams that
literally that's the role to improve the
processes but they cannot code they
don't know how to code they're
they understand legal processes they
understand sales processes they
understand marketing courses
there they can do amazing stuff in in a
spreadsheet you know but they're not
coders um
how can i empower them to build custom
installations because that's kind of
where it all comes down to in my mind
and why you know we're excited about
what we're doing
if you make something that allows people
to do things better
you impact the world for sure but you
impact it in a linear way
if you allow more people to do things
better
you expend the pie then your impact
becomes exponential you don't even know
where it will take you
and we all experience that with an
iphone and what it you know what it
changed the world it's not only the
iphone is the fact that now more people
can write applications to the iphone
created a situation where there's an
application for everything and
completely transform how everyone work
you've never thought about when they
created the iphone they never thought
about
the magnitude and scope of things that
people have built for it and so
similarly we're trying to create a
movement and trying to
instill that concept of you know
iterative approach
literally agile approach to how you run
the business and to do that you need a
framework and architecture that allows
you to do that just like
the cloud allowed you know agile
development in in software development
so you know it's a lot of it's a lot of
stuff but it all comes back to that
very basic concept of
we need to empower more people to
leverage software
i i think that what what leaves me you
know very inspired from
from this conversation you know i i came
in understanding that you know processes
are complicated
data-driven world is complicated there's
a mismatch between the company's ability
to
to connect the business and the and the
data and and make better decisions but
we're actually touching on is something
that's a little bit deeper and you're
actually saying we're actually misusing
the potential of of the people that are
around us and the potential of people in
the company that that could that what
they could do as makers today they may
just they may not have the skills to do
that because frankly coding is you know
just this last generation or maybe two
generations and and even in those
generations the disparity of those that
are able to learn how to code is is
really really is really really big this
disparity and and uh and and bridging
the gap is not easy either and so i
think that
this is this is going to leave me with
with a lot of thoughts and i really want
to thank you for this time
for the last or the last quote that i
just love from please
picasso which is
you know completely random but actually
he said
computers are dumb
they can only answer questions
you know and i think the point is
the hard part is asking the questions
right the our part is something that
that only us creative people can do
and so if we're not enabling people to
do more if we're just trying to automate
or take away
work from them
um or you know just gather data for the
sake of gathering it we haven't done
anything we you know we just um
we just checked the box so
i really really want to thank you uh for
for the time and and and everything and
this was a this is such a pleasure and
inspiring thank you for
uh for for spending this time with me
and best of luck with with tonkin and
with everything else that you're doing
and stay safe and stay out thank you i
appreciate it man thank you for the time
[Music]